foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
Marsha Blackburn
believes
that rich people quote rich people
borrow money to pay for their children's
and their grandchildren's college this
is really [ __ ] stupid
I can't even believe that
we have to say this out loud to people
who quite understand what it feels like
to be [ __ ] broke
Marcia Blackburn goes on Fox news this
morning now I I don't know if she's just
this [ __ ] stupid or she's lying to
people
and this isn't like headline news or
anything but it should be and the reason
why is because right now right now
currently right now there are millions
of people going online to a simple
website it's government website it's
easy to fill out all you have to do is
fill out your information put in your
information that the government already
has here's the reason why they have it
folks is because they subsidized your
loan
it's a loan you took from the government
to pay for your school
that they are charging you astronomical
interest and have been for a long time
and all's Joe Biden did well he did
other things other than just this good
things but all Joe Biden did is say you
know what if you just fill out this
simple form on the internet
we'll know who you are because we are
the one who gave you the loan
and we will just we're not going to give
you anything there's nothing to give you
so you won't get anything
we're just gonna not charge you the rest
of your debt
up to a certain amount
and Marcia Blackburn goes on Fox news
this morning and says
that she went again
I'm gonna play the clip it is
it really isn't that funny that that she
is able to talk like this
and be a United States Senator
she is able to lie like this on [ __ ]
television
in front of a camera with a [ __ ]
microphone
20 30 years ago if a United States
sitting Senator went on a TV station and
said this [ __ ] they may have to resign
I'm not [ __ ] you
because their intelligence would be
called into question
right now on the internet everyone is
[ __ ] wondering wondering if John
fetterman is capable of being a senator
and they're listening to Marcia
Blackburn tell Fox News
foreign
debt relief is a gift quote a gift to
rich people
she went to
the University of Tennessee's football
game
everyone knows now the famous game
between Tennessee and Alabama they tore
down the goal posters video of the
college President saying asking how much
it'll cost they're trying to they're
trying to even pimp donations which is
kind of gross I gotta admit this college
who charges all this [ __ ] money to
have these huge [ __ ] endowments
billions of dollars in endowments are
asking for people to pay for the goal
post that was torn down
give me a [ __ ] break when the
president was standing in the [ __ ]
the goddamn
uh box box seat saying ah [ __ ] who cares
how much it cost we won and now they're
gonna ask for people to give money the
[ __ ] out of here with this nonsense
but Marsha Blackburn says she went to
the University of Tennessee and Alabama
game
and then everyone she ran into at the
game as if anyone would know who the
[ __ ] she was
everyone she ran into at the game in her
little box Suite probably you know all
the rich [ __ ] Republicans
these [ __ ] fascists who she's rubbing
elbows with at the Tennessee football
game all of them
all of them are highly upset
at student debt relief
because it's a gift to rich people look
[ __ ] number one rich people
don't take student loans I don't know
how many times I have to say this into a
microphone
people who take student debt are not
rich you're not rich you're not
you have no [ __ ] clue what rich is no
no idea no unearthly idea what the [ __ ]
wealth actually is if you actually dug
into how much wealth
not the top one percent but the 10 below
them had you would be amazed at how
broke you [ __ ] are
how broke you are do you know the reason
why inflation sucks so much it ain't
because inflation raises the price of
fewer milk the price of fewer milk is
not that high you aren't making enough
money to pay for it
wages suck
and it's designed that way just like
it's designed for Marsha Blackburn to
tell you that student debt relief
is for [ __ ] rich people
and broke [ __ ] in Tennessee
who have Trump Flags in their front yard
who are bowing at the altar of trump
who love white supremacy because that's
the only reason why you would like
Marsha Blackburn frankly that [ __ ]
[ __ ] she [ __ ] she she took money she
took money and protected Pharma we're
going to talk about we're going to talk
about [ __ ] fentanyl later on with
Texas Paul and this [ __ ] border [ __ ]
with fentanyl and the [ __ ] lies that
people like Marsha Blackburn are [ __ ]
spreading and that that [ __ ] two-bit
piece of [ __ ] took [ __ ] money
to make sure that people in Tennessee
were hooked hooked on the [ __ ]
so give me a [ __ ] break on that
but Marcia Blackburn has the [ __ ]
goal to get on [ __ ] national
television and saying to a camera that
the only people that are gonna receive
student debt relief are rich people you
if you believe this if you even give
this an inkling if you are not laughing
at what she says in this clip you are a
dumb [ __ ] you are a dumb son of
a [ __ ]
number one I'm gonna show you I'm gonna
show you today on the show the [ __ ]
website
how [ __ ] easy it is to sign up for
student debt relief if you have it
and the reason why it's so [ __ ] easy
is because you borrowed money from the
federal government they subsidized it
they backed alone
it's their loan hour loan
and they charge the interest they're
making money off you that 10 grand that
they're gonna give you in student debt
relief that probably will barely cover
the interest
this is really [ __ ] bone-headed [ __ ]
that somehow this student debt relief
package that Joe Biden did and the
relief that they're giving right now
right now you can go sign up for your
relief right now and I I you better go
[ __ ] do it
you better right now get into a contract
with the federal government to make sure
that they [ __ ] that they get rid of
your debt because you better weld God
damn guarantee that if anyone like
[ __ ] Marcia Blackburn takes any kind
of power anywhere and has any say over
it they're not gonna let you [ __ ]
participate in this program they're
going to strip it away from you
so right now if you're in Tennessee and
you're a broke [ __ ] and you're
voting for people like Marsha Blackburn
and [ __ ] Donald Trump you better get
online and you better [ __ ] get rid of
your student debt now because when you
vote for these [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
fascists they are not gonna let you do
that only Joe Biden is gonna let you do
that right now you dumb [ __ ]
this is the dumbest [ __ ] thing I this
is the stupidest [ __ ] clip I have I
watch a lot of [ __ ] Clips we play a
lot of [ __ ] Clips there's a lot of
Herschel Walker says some dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can't even understand and this is
the dumbest [ __ ] thing I've heard a
sitting United States senators say in a
long goddamn time
and really honestly her constituents in
Tennessee
because they're they're one of the
brokest [ __ ] States in this country
and the reason why is because they elect
people like Marsha Blackburn
because they believe this nonsense that
rich people take out student loan debt
and Joe Biden is forgiving the rich
people student don't let need debt do
you even remember 2000 and [ __ ] eight
or twelves excuse me Jesus Christ
there's so many [ __ ] Landmark
elections in this country
2012 when Barack Obama ran against Mitt
Romney Mitt Romney said well what do you
what are you worried about college for
just borrow a million dollars from your
parents you remember that
just borrow the money to go to college
from your parents
we have come a long way apparently in
the last 10 years that Marcia Blackburn
is now saying on National Television
that the student debt Rel and I'm going
to show you the evidence of why it's not
true it's really simple to sniff this
out this this is not hard
why it is the dumbest [ __ ] thing a
United sitting United States senators
ever said and really honestly this
morning Marcia Blackburn and her staff
should be preparing her resignation in
any normal circumstance
any normal [ __ ] world not some kind
of trumped up timeline that we're
[ __ ] living in
but any normal [ __ ] world
a sitting United States Center to go on
TV and tell such a [ __ ] lie
would be called into question not just
on that interview but reporters in
Washington would be following that
[ __ ] around the entire [ __ ]
day for weeks on end trying to figure
out what are they just this [ __ ] dumb
how in the [ __ ] are you in United States
Senator
I'll tell you why Marshall Blackburn
said this it's not because I mean she is
[ __ ] stupid but it's not because
she's [ __ ] dumb
nothing to do with it
she's a Nazi
that's why
she's trying to convince people her
constituents not just in Tennessee but
all around the country
to not apply for the student debt relief
that's what they're doing
they're going to tell people don't worry
about don't even go don't even think
about applying for it it's only rich
people that are going to get it
because you know what they want to have
happen
they want to make sure that the dumbest
of the dumb who have student debt and
don't have student debt believe that
they were not afforded afford given the
opportunity to relieve their debt
because they're broke or they're poor
are there Republican are there
conservatives or they're Trump
supporters it says nothing on the
application about who you [ __ ]
prescribe to politically not a God damn
bit
matter of fact on the [ __ ] form that
you fill out
online I'm going to show you this I'm
going to show you the [ __ ] form
because I think it's vitally important
that Americans right now we have
students that go and put this their
information into this system
it says right there on the Forum that
you have to make under a certain amount
of money
and that's what Marcia Blackburn is
saying
she's saying that families
who make under 250 000 a year
are rich
that's she's saying
and the reason why she can say it to
people in Tennessee is because people
like her have been in charge for so long
and they've kept their [ __ ] foot on
the necks of people in Tennessee so
[ __ ] long
that the people in Tennessee really
believe that a family who makes 250 000
a year is [ __ ] loaded
well I'm here to tell you I'm here to
tell you and I hate to disappoint you I
hate to disappoint you and I know some
people even in my audience are gonna
disagree with me but families who make
250 000 a year
they may feel rich in Tennessee but
they're not rich you're not
you're not you're barely middle class
these people had convinced you of stupid
ass [ __ ] and one thing is that you're
gonna be rich One Day You're Gonna Be
Elon Rich do you own a [ __ ] Diamond
Mind
you're gonna be Trump Rich did your
daddy give you a hundred million 200
million dollars
you are bone-headed [ __ ]
and we have lost our way in this country
the American dream is not to to [ __ ]
every person in sight to get as much
money as you possibly can that was not
the American dream
to just be swimming like Scrooge McDuck
in mountains of money that's not that
wasn't the American dream
your grandpappy
that wasn't his American Dream the
migrants the immigrants who have come
here in this country who have worked
their entire lives to build a life for
their families here in this country that
wasn't their American Dream
it was tab Liberty
the pursuit of happiness
a place to live
a lifestyle
to relax to enjoy our country
to enjoy the culture
to enjoy The View
to enjoy the people
that was the American dream
and these fascists have deluded us down
so [ __ ] much
that Marcia Blackburn can go on on
[ __ ] television
and lie
that rich people take student loans
foreign
rich people
give millions of dollars
to universities to make sure that their
children and their grandchildren
get special treatment at these schools
rich people give millions of dollars
money that you will never dream of
having to be able to give to a
university so that your kin
can have special treatment at that
school
and if we are in a situation where
Americans
can be lied to you on such a little
simple fact like this
Jesus Christ
I can't even imagine
when I was in high school over 20 years
ago yeah it's been that long
I can't even [ __ ] imagine
having having the goal
even in even in the Rural America that I
grew up in to even utter the thought in
my brain
that rich people took student loan debt
why do you think there is student loan
debt
because they convinced us
that the only way to become the rich
people that don't have to take student
loans is to take the debt in the first
place
again
in any normal time if the United States
sitting senator
especially from one of the poorest
[ __ ] states in the nation
went on national TV
and said
that student debt relief
was a gift
to rich people
the state would prob they would probably
have a petition in the state
for that Senator to [ __ ] resign
doesn't matter the party
I don't give a [ __ ] the party I don't
care how what if you're a man if you're
a woman I don't care if you're rich
you're poor as a senator I don't even
care you're [ __ ] your your your your
[ __ ] bird nest hairdo I don't give a
[ __ ]
Tennessee and people in Tennessee this
morning
they should be infuriated the news
agencies and the media in Tennessee
should be playing this clip
back to back to back to back a Marsha
Blackburn demeaning people of Tennessee
lying to people of Tennessee
outright line either that or trying to
question her mental state
and if she's fit to be a senator
because she is so goddamn dumb
that she believes that student debt
relief is a gift to rich people
foreign
this is where we're at and this is why
this election is so [ __ ] important
because they're telling you who they are
they're even telling their supporters
they're trumped-up supporters who they
are
that that I'm willing to [ __ ] lie to
you because you're so goddamn complicit
that you won't just go check
that you can't even you can't even
adhere Jesus Christ
how in the hell don't broke ass people
in this country know that rich people
don't pay
don't take student loans for college how
in the [ __ ] don't you know that
but they don't care
and that's why this election is so
goddamn important we're 21 days three
weeks to the day
hell we had a bunch of damn debates last
night and I really wanted to talk about
how Tim Ryan dunked JD Vance and trash
and I'm sure I'm gonna get to that today
I mean we got we got two [ __ ] hours
we got Texas Park coming on because it's
Tuesday we got two hours damn right you
damn right I'm gonna show you how Tim
Ryan wadded up JD Vance and stuffed him
in a [ __ ] Locker again
Evan McMillan absolutely destroyed
destroyed Mike Lee
Herschel Walker didn't show up to his
debate but he went and let Sean Hannity
tell him talking points why he nodded
his head
at a campaign event on Fox News
Stacy Abrams
destroyed destroyed
the defund the police [ __ ]
but if these [ __ ] will believe
the [ __ ] that Marcia Blackburn said on
Fox news this morning if they'll believe
that
they're gonna believe [ __ ] anything
folks
anything
I mean absolutely [ __ ] anything
do not do not doubt them
and I mean the [ __ ] voters these
people are gonna go vote are you
because if if you're for people in this
country who took out a shitload of
[ __ ] debt to try to get ahead in the
economy and it held them back all this
time even with a degree or without it
and just need a little bit of help a
little bit of a hand up for the
government to say hey that money you owe
us don't forget about it it's not giving
them anything you're not giving them
anything
if you're against that
whoosh
but they're not even against that folks
the people who Marshall Blackburn's
talking to
would be like goddamn right people who
can't afford college should be given
College they should be giving their
student debt for free
and the only reason why they're saying
the opposite right now the only reason
why they're saying the opposite right
now is the same reason why Rhonda Sands
is criminally criminally
trafficked migrants from Venezuela
who are seeking Refuge from Texas to
Martha's venue and it's only to own the
libs
it's ridiculous
it's absolutely [ __ ] bonkers
it's in a Twilight type Zone timeline
because that's what we are folks we are
at the intersection of WrestleMania and
real life
and they don't give a [ __ ] about the
truth they don't give a [ __ ] about it
they know the truth they don't give a
[ __ ] about it
again in any normal reality
Marsha Blackburn this morning if she
would say that on on a in front of a
[ __ ] camera
would be absolutely inundated her press
office couldn't [ __ ] write statements
and excuses quick enough
about how she misspoke and she didn't
really mean that [ __ ]
not a p
IC not a [ __ ] peep not a Pete from
Tennessee not a peep from her
constituents not a [ __ ] peep
because they want these [ __ ] to
lie
they want them to lie
that's the only way they're gonna win
they can't win with the truth
so what are you gonna do
are you gonna let them win with lies is
that what you're gonna do because you
still have a choice and you better oh
baby
you better use your vote before you lose
it
it's next they're gonna come for that
[ __ ]
if you think United States senators like
Marsha Blackburn will go on [ __ ]
National TV in front of a camera and a
microphone and lie outright lie
that rich people are the ones who are
getting student debt relief from this
package that the Biden Administration
has put together
they damn sure will lie to you that you
don't need to vote
you goddamn right they'll lie to you
just like they'll lie to you and say ah
that you know that stuff about you know
needing medical procedures to save your
life because you because you're you lost
your baby
are you having ectopic pregnancy or
whatever the medical condition that you
may risk your life or you were raped
or it was due to incest uh forget about
that that's not real
forget about that we don't we don't need
to have exceptions you think you think
they're going to have exceptions
when it comes to your vote especially
when you're voting against them
I don't think you're listening to them
if that's the truth
if you really think these people won't
go
to the absolute bottom the absolute
bottom to create the fascist state that
they want to tell you what the [ __ ] you
can do and how the [ __ ] you can think
you are out of your mind
and this clip of Marsha Blackburn is
proof today we're going to watch that
clip and also today we've got Texas Paul
you know it's Tuesday
Texas Paul every single Tuesday I'm
excited to talk to Texas Paul we're
going to talk about one subject but he
was like nope
there was too much of this word fentanyl
in these debates last night too much of
this fentanyl stuff they're using it to
try to scare people
and the SK there is a scary part about
this fentanyl thing but it's not what
these Republicans are saying
at all so Texas fall is going to break
that down today for us we're going to
talk to him about the Texas border and
Fentanyl I I also want to show yesterday
uh Lauren bobert tweeted about this of
course she did uh so we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna look at that tweet and
maybe that's where we'll start with
dex's ball is with that tweet but also
we're going to do the shitless Roundup
today don't forget to we're gonna go
through these vidges
these videos out there we got tons of
Clips I want to show you uh JD Vance
absolutely getting dunked in the Trish
in the Trish by Tim Ryan getting
destroyed by of course he would it even
such a cuck how in the [ __ ] would JD
Vance agree to debate Tim Ryan what a
dumb decision that was by J.D Vance what
an idiot I mean he just he absolutely
absolutely 100 lost that debate before
he even showed up everybody
thank you for all the support the
audience is growing there's so many
people here right now live watching the
Tony Michaels podcast don't forget to go
to
store.dtonymichaels.com and pick up the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty merch holy [ __ ]
these things are flying off the shelves
I guess it's getting cold all around the
country like it is here in Missouri
because you guys are buying these
hoodies and zip-up hoodies like crazy we
also got t-shirts over there the freedom
to oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty
it's the show motto here store dot the
Tony michaels.com go pick up your
Liberty merch today we got coffee mugs
over there as well but everyone is
getting ready for winter and grabbing
the hoodies we also have zip up hoodies
I'm thinking about putting sweaters over
there
you guys you guys like the uh the winter
wear so much I think I might put some
sweaters over there too for you guys to
have you got to keep warm [ __ ] when
we're out there voting when you're
standing in line and you're gonna go
vote here in three weeks you gotta keep
warm and you gotta support Liberty
because the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] thank you for all
your support you're a great audience
everyone stick around Texas Paul when we
come back from the break we'll be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Mega
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
it's Tuesday
favorite day
as always
as promised
Mighty favorite
Paul is here with us today Texas Paul
how are you this morning my friend man I
am wonderful I am wonderful pumpkin
spice to you my friend pumpkin spice you
like the pumpkin spice stuff huh I just
do regular I can't ever wait for this
time of year to come around man that is
my that is my favorite
I love it I love it
yep
I'm not sure the Hat's on tied for today
brother it's going to get get a little
ripe get a little while last week you
brought the heat I mean last week last
week people were taking the clips of
that of that interview and they were
posting it all around the internet Tick
Tock Twitter they were like holy [ __ ]
Texas Paul showed up with a Blue Torch
today because you did you absolutely
endorsed these people now we were going
to talk about something originally but
you're like no I want to switch this
fentanyl thing there's too many mentions
of this word fentanyl in the uh debates
last night uh yeah last night watching
the debates man it was just frustrating
as hell because it was like watching you
know carbon copy I watched Mike Lee I
watched Camp I watched you know uh
Tim Ryan kicked the [ __ ] out of JD Vance
and every one of them it was the exact
same line Mexican drugs Mexican cartels
Mexican smuggling drugs across the
southern border we need a wall blah blah
blah
trying to scare these people uh of brown
people it almost like they're they're
resurrecting the the crime rape
murderers some of them are good people
seems like they're trying to revive that
[ __ ]
yeah it's a caravan's all over again
every election they do it every election
there's a caravan coming it's the same
[ __ ] it is it's and it's [ __ ]
and I brought receipts well here's here
is um
here's the tweet that I was referring to
of Lauren bobert now if anyone doesn't
know this bonehead is a current sitting
congresswoman which I don't know how
that's even possible we need to fix that
and you can fix that here in less in
three weeks you can fix that and really
honestly Colorado's got some early
voting um going on so you better get get
to it and get rid of this scumbag but
she tweets this dexus Paul she's in
Colorado she says this problem starts in
Texas then flows to the rest of our
nation
we have got to get a grip on this
fentanyl fuel crisis taking over our
country and she cites a Fox News article
okay and if anyone can read this here
I'm not going to read the article but
the headline here says Texas border
agent sees keyword there over one
million in alleged fentanyl of course
then it's got the uh you know the scary
little picture here but it's got the CNN
logo on it you know they got it they
gotta do that too because it's the
liberal media bringing in this Fentanyl
um so give us give us your thoughts on
this but first thing
on the debates last night
do you do you think that this fentanyl
talk from the Republicans has effect
yeah it does because people don't the
border is a foreign area to
99.9999 of of Americans Even in our
border towns they make up such they're
small cities they're not large cities
um you know except for San Diego which
is the only real large city on the
border
um people Americans don't know what the
southern border is they don't know that
almost the entire Southern border is
human-less
there's nothing there it is pure desert
it's it it
I mean if you go out if you get out in
New Mexico Arizona all that area in
there that entire part of the Southern
border there's not a human if you get
lost out there you're a dead man I'm
telling you there's nothing there
and people don't know that so it's easy
to tell them [ __ ] about it
especially if you make it a real scary
story about them Mexican people and them
drug cartels that's him doing it right
there when it's not it's [ __ ] Billy
Bob it's [ __ ] Billy Bob in the U.S
mail
that's exactly who's doing it wait wait
wait wait you're telling
you're telling United States postal
s and other shipping
country private organ private business
are shipping this stuff into our country
is that what you're saying I'm telling
you the DEA will tell you the number one
drug mule for Fenton Hill is the United
States mail service period son of a
[ __ ]
where is this being mailed from is it
being mailed from the drug cartels in
Mexico no it's being mailed from China
the same Labs that make it for made it
for the pharmaceutical companies China
back in 2019 uh because Trump's an idiot
and doesn't know that fentanyl actually
had a medical use uh insisted that China
uh if they wanted to work smooth out our
trade agreements made fentanyl
completely illegal so the labs that were
making fentanyl for drug companies here
in the United States
uh by the way people your your drugs are
not made here they're made in China you
know they like to tell you about foreign
drugs being dangerous and don't buy
drugs from Canada because it's dangerous
but your drugs right here made in
[ __ ] China like everything else
but those labs said well we got to make
something so they uh China made the law
said you can't manufacture fentanyl
anymore so
they took all of the ingredients all the
precursors everything
manufacture those
they put them on Facebook for [ __ ]
Facebook I am not kidding the number one
seller of illicit fentanyl in this
country uses Facebook LinkedIn and
Twitter as his primary source of sales
then he puts it in the United States
Postal
envelope and mails it from China
and your people pick it up
right and it's so cheap to manufacture
he's he's even got a guarantee if they
find it we'll we'll mail you more
I'm not kidding I'm not even kidding
well you know some of the failed
Fentanyl
pop country and and by failed fentanyl
policy
I mean the actual [ __ ] truth is
Republicans they'll go on Fox News and
say if you touch fentanyl you'll die not
and people being none the wiser they've
taken probably taken fentanyl in their
life before and have no clue that they
have taken it they just don't know
because it is a prescription
also there's like a medical use like you
said for fentanyl where the hell do you
think it's a synthetic opioid right and
and it it's absolutely
ridiculous that they can go on live TV
just like Marsha Blackburn said this
morning on live TV that rich P that that
student debt relief is a gift to rich
people what a [ __ ] liar but she's the
same [ __ ] liar who supported the drug
companies with fentanyl
she supported the drug companies dumping
opioids into Tennessee communities and
destroying and that's exactly that's
exactly where this started from that's
exactly where this started from was the
opioid crisis that made that fat piece
of [ __ ] bastard Rush Limbaugh deaf
I don't know if you remember that I oh
yeah that was a happy day in my life
when I found out that [ __ ] did
some smoke so much oxy that he went deaf
but uh I celebrate that every year it's
a holiday in this house and Rush
Limbaugh death day is that what you know
yeah yeah deaf [ __ ] day we call
it around here you know you know I want
to congratulate I want to congratulate
rushland ball for being drug-free for so
long it is uh yeah we only had to die to
do it right
the guy with the back injury that used
to golf every day that that guy
you know he was taking he was taking all
that oxy because he had a back injury we
have an Adderall shortage now and they
couldn't mention that because they're
they're King their King and Mussolini
Jesus is suffering from the Adderall
surge uh we got Gabe Sanchez here uh
Gabe are you keeping up with our
conversation I want to make sure you're
on track here I'm drawing the vent and
I'll talk yeah no I'm trying I'm just
trying to uh just I'm trying to get back
my old prescription for Adderall but
it's hard I can tell you that for a fact
it is hard
well you know I don't blame you I don't
blame you Texas ball you were saying
that this is where it's all started is
is this yeah
you know everybody remembers the oxy
crisis right so they made that illegal
so a lot of people first thing they did
was they went to heroin
and we had a huge heroin crisis around
2010 if you remember everybody was
talking about heroin was just out of
control and you know that's one of the
great reasons we were in Afghanistan
because we could just take those poppy
fields out and yada yada yada yada
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
so we had a heroin crisis well people
don't realize heroin is actually a
pretty low-grade opioid it's not you
know oxy was much stronger than heroin
so to spice it up a little bit drug men
you know drug dealers started mixing
fentanyl with their heroin
and heroin users are like oh yeah baby
this is what we want
we want this and since you know as time
went on they just quit putting the
heroin in it and everybody started
smoking Fenton now they're smoking this
[ __ ] man they crush it and smoke it I'm
not even kidding I mean
but I'm telling you
there's a reason they're saying this one
it's the old Caravan [ __ ] again
blame it on Mexico
that's one aspect of it the other aspect
of it is they don't want this Trace back
to they cost this the Republicans and
their deal with the Devil with the
[ __ ] drug companies that allowed oxy
to be pumped all over our country you
know they were dumping it on veterans
veterans would come in and say man I
tell you I've got depression here has
some oxycontin
they were pushing that [ __ ] like it was
[ __ ] candy to veterans you know we
had a huge opioid crisis addiction
crisis with our veterans that's why we
had so many goddamn suicides they
weren't getting treated for depression
they were given another [ __ ]
depressant on top of it
you know I mean and then instead of
wanting to deal with that crisis that
Republicans created of course they're
not going to sit there in a debate and
say yeah we kind of did this [ __ ] we're
the reason fentanyl's here they want to
turn around and say brown people brown
people did it be scared build the wall
you know like walls have worked since
what 1066 in the Battle of Hastings was
the last time a [ __ ] wall worked for
anything as the U.S does the U.S mail
have to go through the wall is that is
that to get the big home through I don't
know if that the U.S mail is actually
working on fixing this problem they know
they've got this problem
um
these are these are small packages right
these aren't yeah
it's it's in a small little package like
a like see this is jewelry or something
would be in
this is what is another problem that
they created when they when [ __ ]
Trump went to China and said you have to
make fentanyl illegal fentanyl in its
pure form is a hundred times more
powerful
than heroin
okay and wait a minute it's like a
thousand times more powerful than Aaron
and heroin 100 times more powerful than
oxy I mean it's just incredibly in its
pure form incredibly powerful and they
will mail a package the side I mean this
big I mean you saw the picture of those
packages They seized that's in the back
of a pickup okay these are small
packages these are not this is the ones
right these are not huge packages you
can mail that and that's cut fentanyl
right there that's not pure
that's cut fit no right there a pure
package of fentanyl is so freaking small
and something you said earlier about
fentanyl can't kill you you must open a
package of pure Fentanyl and you're not
wearing a resuscitator and a bunny suit
it will drop you instantly right but
what they're saying the lie that they're
telling because this is this is the
propaganda that they do they use a
kernel of truth right and they act like
this is because they did this with hot
they're doing this with Halloween candy
and I know why they're doing it with the
Halloween because it's in the lead-up to
the election right right and and I've
even seen I think it was good liars had
a video where a woman was like yeah
these and I think we showed it on the
show didn't we Gabe where's she's like
yeah these illegals are coming across
the country are coming across the border
in our country they're gonna set up and
hand this stuff out to for free two
children to kill them I I it it doesn't
make any sense like at all well if I I
can throw one more thing out there
that's just a real kick in the nuts
about this we know the Cato Institute
and you know guys I don't agree with the
Cato Institute I don't agree with them
they they tell the audience the Cato
Institute is first the Cato Institute is
a Libertarian Institute that's why I
don't agree with them very much but they
are honest okay I will tell you this
they will take and look at a situation
and they will give you accurate 100
facts
but their suppositions from those facts
I don't agree with because I'm not a
Libertarian I don't think taxes are a
crime I don't think that the
government's evil I don't think you know
our currency is a fiat currency all the
[ __ ] that Libertarians believe I I don't
believe that but Cato doesn't lie about
their facts and they have taken a look
at you know who's smuggling by who gets
arrested and prosecuted
they they looked at the numbers
over 85 percent are Americans
and it's not they're driving that [ __ ]
across the border in their [ __ ]
pickup trucks it's not what it is it's
really not that is a small small
fraction with the fentanyl trade it's
[ __ ] Bubba in Cincinnati
getting his mail package
setting up his lab just like they used
to set up speed Labs wrapping in this
[ __ ] house in plastic on the inside
and getting a [ __ ] bunny suit from
Breaking Bad
so he can cut the [ __ ] open without
stopping his [ __ ] heart
and they mix it uphill press you can buy
a [ __ ] pill press on Amazon people
you can buy a pill press on Amazon
an automated pill press I'm not even
kidding all he has to do is cut the
[ __ ] bag of fentanyl open mix it with
with you know they used to use back in
the day they would use it I just wanna I
just want to preface that this is not an
instructional video I just wanna this is
not this is not an instructional video
we are not and we will not discuss why I
know how this works either so no I'm
just kidding I am just kidding I am just
I read people I read okay
um he's read on how to set up a drug
exactly exactly
I I've never set one up in my life okay
that we know of
stuff
and this is not an instructional video
but here's the thing though is is it's
the lies about fentanyl that we're
talking about here because the truth the
truth is actually very damning when you
talk about Fentanyl and what I mean by
that is it's destroying lives it's
destroying lives right and and the
reason why it's destroying lives is not
because it's it's fentanyl in particular
but it's because it's the easiest opioid
now to grab a hold of right like before
and heroin then it was Oxycontin and
then that went away now it's fentanyl
right and when we get rid of the
fentanyl problem we're still going to
have an opioid problem because this is
the thing we have health care problems
in this country this is stems from a
health care issue that's what this is
this is a health care issue and if we
get on board to fix this problem but
it's the lies from the Republican side
from this debate so what were some of
those lies that were told last night in
particular of course I know they're
going to be recycled but can you recall
exactly what the lies were about
Fentanyl and some of these debates from
the Republicans they were who are you
asking why either one I don't want them
Joey yeah um it's the exact same thing
we have to build the wall because our
Southern border is wide open Joe Biden
somehow without changing a single law
because the one law they tried to change
has been set aside by a judge and is
being adjudicated in the courts right
now so literally nothing's changed but
the policy of not caging kids
and and treat people like humans human
beings yeah that's the only thing that's
changed is that they insist that we
don't break up families we don't need
anything like that okay that's the only
change somehow Joe Biden opened the
southern border they said it all night
last night Joe Biden opened our Southern
border
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it's the same [ __ ] law title
42 same law that was in place under
Trump
period they the Republicans blocked
uh every time the the Democrats tried to
put immigration reform in any Bill the
Republicans blocked it because they
wanted this for this election
they wanted us for this election they
wanted a
humanitarian crisis and that's why
border patrol agents will tell you if
you talk to them and you can talk to
them off the Record they will tell you
they don't need to be dealing with this
this is not a police issue this is a
humanitarian issue [ __ ] FEMA needs to
be down here not us
law enforcement
yeah
cbp's law enforcement and they're
telling you you are trying to stop the
humanitarian problem with with the law
enforcement law enforcement solution and
it doesn't work it's not going to work
all it does is make a fat [ __ ] racist
somewhere up in Nebraska feel good
that's that that's all that does
I mean
I was going to say is uh because I mean
you know Republicans love to run on this
this platform we got to build the wall
build the wall build the wall we got to
separate we got to isolate we got to
make sure that no you know Mexicans or
Guatemalans or Venezuelans or whoever
they might be can come up to the
southern border which by the way you
know we've talked about it before on the
show
um
building a wall through the southern
border terrain is [ __ ] ridiculous if
you want to go build through the terrain
of mountains and what I mean like there
are photos but like literally we have to
leave this get this 20-foot Gap here
because we cannot build up on this
actual stone
uh mountainous range
but Republicans think that oh yeah we
could just we could just build a wall
through anything which is like I mean
yeah
[ __ ] fat dude in Nebraska right
Nebraska it's like well why can't you
build a wall hell i'll build a wall at
my field it just do you know what a
[ __ ] ecological disaster if they
actually did Build That Wall do you know
what kind of [ __ ] ecological disaster
that would be do you know how many
species don't give a [ __ ] about your
imaginary [ __ ] border
they don't see your map right and they
run back across back and forth across
that [ __ ] border I hunt on the
southern border folks let me tell you
there are Russian board there are feral
Hogs there are and feral Hawks will tear
the [ __ ] out of your fence in a
heartbeat they will they'll dig that
[ __ ] up in a heartbeat feral hogs in
Texas there's an overpopulation problem
right now
huge huge you can shoot it you can shoot
a wild pig anytime you want anywhere
it's yeah it's I mean if that if that
fucker's running through your
neighborhood you can shoot that [ __ ] I
think really hey we have a huge Federal
big problem down here uh because we had
a huge pig farmer down in South Texas a
long long time ago about 80 years ago
shut his operation down turned his pigs
out and now we have millions of pigs
running around South Texas but anyways
or something yeah it's almost like yeah
it's on and it's almost like they're
smarter you know after the border wall
though real quick because that's another
[ __ ] line that they say because the
administration right now is currently
struggling with fixing the [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass wall that Trump built because it is
a government mandate to protect its
property and its property is the [ __ ]
[ __ ] fence that [ __ ] Trump built and
he built it it was not staying up
garbage right it won't stay up a lot of
it and it's not just the the animals
going across the border it's the water
the [ __ ] water has taken a lot of
these these goddamn these goddamn um
pieces of fence out and the federal
government is struggling to keep these
pieces of fence up because they're
mandated to do that that's the thing
about [ __ ] government when you make a
decision to do something you have to
commit to doing it even if it's really
[ __ ] dumb right and Republicans do
really dumb [ __ ] in government to make
government even dumber that's what they
do and that's why this fentanyl thing is
so stupid because they have caused a lot
of the problems that that is that is the
market of Fentanyl and what I mean by
that is people who are sick from dope it
is a sickness it is a health care issue
this is what it is it is not it is not a
crime issue it is not a [ __ ] family
issue or domestic issue it is a [ __ ]
Health Care issue that is what it is
frankly most of the addiction starts
from our health care System right that's
where the [ __ ] [ __ ] starts is these
people which is exactly why they they
want to say this [ __ ] which is exactly
why they want to say this [ __ ] they are
in bed with the pharmaceutical companies
who are responsible for starting this
[ __ ] crisis and they want to divert
and they want to point across the border
and and they said the shittiest things
about Mexico last night and let me tell
you something
Mexico should be [ __ ] they are pissed
at us to be quite honest with you they
really have you ever heard of Rio de
jiero
that y'all ever heard of that it's kind
of an expression down in Mexico it's
called The Iron River
you know what that is that's the flow of
[ __ ] guns from us to them
there's one [ __ ] Gun Store Wait wow
wow wow wait a second Texas Paul
everybody knows that [ __ ] doesn't flow
across the border that Direction come on
Texas Park you telling me that that we
caused the Border crisis by sending our
manufactured guns across the border
don't you accuse there's one
hard-working white American Gun Store
one [ __ ] gun store in the country of
Mexico one it is in Mexico City it is
run by the government they sell about 30
to 40 guns a day
period that's it it takes about three
months to do all the paperwork just to
be able to walk into that [ __ ] store
it's run by the the military
it's you cannot go down to Mexico and
just buy a gun at a gun store like you
can here they come across the border
they buy guns at guns shows here from
private individuals all these [ __ ]
AR-15s you hear about and this that and
the other well I tell you what bub is
doing he's buying a 600 piece of [ __ ]
AR-15 and he's shipping it to Mexico for
1500 bucks and that's what they don't
want to [ __ ] stop
that's why they want to talk about
everything coming this way and they want
to talk about violence in Mexico well
let me tell you the Mexican police are
goddamn tired of every time they have a
shootout they pick up a [ __ ] gun
it's you know and they trace it back to
the United States they're really [ __ ]
tired of that they're tired of getting
shot by our [ __ ] guns that's what
they're really tired of and they're
really tired of us running our mouths
about how terrible the people in Mexico
are when they're actually trying to do
something to stop violence and then
you've got Greg Abbott here who's making
it super [ __ ] easy for any idiot to
walk around if you are a goddamn cartel
member
you can walk around my state with a
[ __ ] AR-15 slung them across your
back and a cop can't ask you a goddamn
thing about it
wait wait are you saying are you saying
that cartel members are welcome in Texas
as long as they got a rifle slung over
their shoulder as long as they're buying
guns they are
and Greg Greg Abbott won't do a goddamn
thing about it not a thing I mean that's
bad for business that's bad for these
gun manufacturers that that own Greg
Abbott you know hook line zinker that is
really bad you got to make sure that the
flow or their product is across that
border otherwise why would you have Greg
Abbott as the governor in the first
place I mean yeah really Texas ball I
mean come on man you know that that's
why they're talking about that's why the
the Republicans are talking about uh
that one of them got caught on the tape
the other day I forget his name they
want to eliminate the ATF completely
eliminate the ATF that's why you're
seeing the surge in quote ghost guns
because way too often these guns down in
Mexico we're exporting our [ __ ]
problems Canada hates us for that [ __ ]
too
you know Canada regulates their gun
purchases man they do but people come
across the border they buy one throw it
in the trunk of their car and drive home
you know it's just [ __ ] insane you
can buy a gun have it mailed to a
[ __ ] dealer who's by the way the
dealer is some guy named Chad that lives
over on Mulberry Street that got his
[ __ ] FFL license who gets a gun
mailed to him from [ __ ] Texas and
then you show up and you sign on the
dotted line and Chad says are you sure
you're you yeah okay thanks and you
leave with your [ __ ] weapon man
[ __ ] you Jenny I mean it's ridiculous
and they don't want to have these
[ __ ] conversations so what do they do
Mexicans it's the Mexicans they're doing
it to us you got to be scared the
Mexicans they're doing it to us [ __ ]
man I put a tweet up the other day and
said yeah these are the people that they
say are invading our country they're
harvesting Tomatoes you got a whole
[ __ ] you got a guy next to a damn
wagon that's 40 feet long chucking
buckets of tomatoes out there that was a
great one oh one after the other one
after the other and I'm like yeah this
is your [ __ ] Invader this is the guy
that's taking your job you know [ __ ]
right it's a load of bulls and they did
it all night in debates last night all
[ __ ] night well I mean I mean that's
that's I mean that's we we know that's
what they do they will they will pass
the blame they will pass the buck that
is how Republicans operate in this
country if they caused a problem or they
complain about a problem they they then
blame somebody else you know especially
if it's someone who is not white right
anyone who doesn't look like them
they're an outcast they're an outsider
they're the problem you know they're the
ones who are causing this this poison
this cancer within our country which is
really the Republican party right so
again it's you have you have a group of
people who are just trying to to achieve
this American Dream who comes to this
country with the with the possibility of
opportunity and then we have a bunch of
white people who say well you know
especially people in the state of Ohio
or Kansas or whatever it might be in
this so we need to protect the southern
border from what from the state that's
below you I mean the problem there isn't
that problem that's for you that's
that's in relation to to Mexico you're
in not a target for them you are someone
who is irrelevant to them they don't
care about you they care about
themselves and their family they're not
coming in this country with free drugs
to hand out to kids they're not coming
to this country with guns to hand out to
other people that's not how this works
and again it's just the Republican Party
trying to create a you know a boogeyman
fake problem that they can fix which
they don't ever actually fix they just
again push it push it push and push it
when they make the problem even worse
you know you talked about big Pharma
earlier I don't know if anyone's seen
dope sick but like that gives you an
inside perspective I mean [ __ ] they even
talk about Rudy Giuliani being a [ __ ]
lobbyist for them and pushing their
their agenda and making sure that they
can get through the legal paths he was
one of the people that actually defended
uh those big Pharma companies when it
came to court so like if there's anyone
you should be blaming you've got to look
at the Republican party and big Pharma
and these people the gun manufacturers
and these other people like those are
the ones who are in bed together and
Chad and Chad [ __ ] Chad because
here's the thing about and here's the
thing about Chad real quick Texas ball
because Chad's got a stockpile of all
these weapons and he's gonna sell right
and he goes to the gun show and he's
selling these [ __ ] weapons to the
cartel to go across the border he knows
that and then he sells it to the white
dude coming up like hey man you better
buy your weapons I just sold a shitload
of weapons to the cartel and boy they're
gonna come and kill you so you better
get you a weapon I mean and that is lit
now they don't say it that way they're
like oh you better be scared him in
cartels boy they're really dangerous
they're arming themselves because I did
it wink
um but that's that's literally what is
happening it's at in some of these
states especially like Texas where there
is this problem with the border and
stuff coming across it but it doesn't
seem like there's much of a problem this
way as it is that way
the last thing I'll say in this is if
American lives are at risk guns drugs
whatever Republicans won't do anything
to actually prevent it no they don't
actually they are not pro-life they will
not prevent you the death the loss of
human life
if it means more money in their pocket
they'll turn a blind eye and you know
you got Greg Abbott pushing the NRA and
you got other people pushing Big Pharma
at the end of the day as long as it
makes them money
not a problem especially if it means the
loss of human life American lives
foreign
let's talk about Chad for a second here
okay Mexico has one [ __ ] gun store
right one
right
not counting [ __ ] Chad and all the
class three dealers that we have around
here okay I just did a Google for you
the little town I live closest to okay
has a population of eighty thousand
all right I live out in the sticks guys
I do but the little town I'm closest to
how many gun stores do you think serve
Uptown of the population of 80 000. in
this in this immediate area I just
Googled gun stores near me
I I would not even dare to guess
I'm impressed that you were that close
I'm impressed it was 38. it was 38.
that's still insane but all right Mexico
has one gun store
my little [ __ ] town of 80 000 peoples
is serviced by 38. before you [ __ ]
count Chad
now Chad's not a registered gun store
right he's just a dealer
you know he just he can buy and sell
commercially legally
you know
we have a [ __ ] problem in this
country we do period and we're exporting
it to Mexico and they're sick of our
[ __ ]
they are
that's why Greg Abbott is being such a
dick to Mexico
I mean there are best trading partner
and Greg Abbott treats Mexico like [ __ ]
I mean he disrespects him at every turn
if you heard the you hear him last night
in the debates talking about it Mexico
and their [ __ ] crime problem and this
hadn't yet and we got to build us a wall
to keep them people out you know no you
don't no you don't have no idea how much
how much goods and really perishable
Goods to boot that comes across that
border every [ __ ] hour every hour
there are truckloads of goods coming to
this country
that we rely on in this country for
trade to make sure that that we have the
[ __ ] that we want to have when we want
to have it because that's the American
way bye guys you know them real cheap
TVs you buy those real cheap TVs you buy
at Walmart those are made in Mexico man
they are they make TVs they make car
parts they make no you can't tell the
truth God damn they make furniture they
make I mean they make all kinds of [ __ ]
that they they drive across the board
before you talk about even the major
massive agricultural trading partner
that Mexico is with us even before you
talk about that even before you talk
about the fact that they are our
Workforce and our agricultural
industry period
I mean in Georgia you know you had Brian
Kemp talking [ __ ] about how this exact
talking point that fentanyl you know we
don't have a border with Mexico but we
got a fentanyl problem because you know
that open border [ __ ] you got a
[ __ ] fentanyl problem because you've
got you know [ __ ] [ __ ] David in
Atlanta that's buying packages of
[ __ ] fentanyl from China oh it's Chad
having mailed to his house Chad's
selling the guns and the fentanyl it's
Chad dude I'm telling you man it's just
the amount of [ __ ] and disrespect
that these people have because they know
they can say that they know they can say
it it's what their voters want to hear
their voters want to hear that same old
lie that that LBJ told if you tell the
lowest white man that he is better than
the highest black man you do not have to
pick his pockets he will turn his
pockets out for you and they know it
it's the same grift it's been going on
forever
they're telling you you wonderful
hard-working toothless bastards are way
better than all those Mexicans
and they want that's what they want to
hear right that's what they want to hear
and that's why this [ __ ] sells because
they know [ __ ] all about the Border
they've never seen it never been to it
never anything they don't want to travel
outside their [ __ ] County much less
go to another country for Christ's sake
you know what I mean Mexicans
Hispanics period whether they're from
Venezuela anywhere have a wonderful
culture of community and family and they
take care of one another you know what I
mean they do things like have one
[ __ ] gun store in the country you
know what I mean so that if you want to
hunt you can go to that one gun store
and pay 500 bucks for a shotgun that you
can buy here for 180 but
because they care about their people
they care about their people that's
Hispanics for you you know what I mean
but what are what are these people do in
these debates you're better than they
are you're better than they are we need
to build a fence to keep those people
out and it's it's it just enrages me man
because I grew up with these people
these are my people
you know that you're talking [ __ ] about
these are my people you're talking [ __ ]
about [ __ ] you I know your people I know
what you're [ __ ] like
I go to [ __ ] monster truck rallies in
in in in I've got family in Omaha I go
to truck and tractor pulls I know what
you [ __ ] are like after you've had a
few beers
you know don't uh you're talking about
you're talking to me I know you're
talking to me no man you know what it's
like in Missouri man this [ __ ]
Hillbillies
let me tell you something about this
seven
it's this it's this uh white trash
mentality
right you go to White America
and I mean White America
where it's a little rural town and he
said a little town like 80 000 Jesus
crash ball that's a that's a big city to
some of us rule folks I grew up in a
little town I grew up in a little town
that has less than 3 000 people
now when you go to these little towns
and it is all white I mean all white
there is no way other than to just say
it out loud to be racist you can't you
can't commit a hate crime in a town
where there's all white people now what
but what happens in these towns is
there's classism
not racism it's classism in these white
towns and what happens is is the people
in the town decide who who are going to
be the lower of them now rather it's a
certain side of town you live on or a
certain place that you live or a certain
name that you have or certain place that
you work or who your family is it's
classism in these towns
and a lot of times in these towns they
even use racial slurs towards the white
folks that are lower quote lower class
and that's where this stuff stems from
exactly what you're saying is because
these people these politicians
especially but these people in power
they they know that Trump knew that
Trump knew that there was this this this
mechanism in in these rural white
communities he knew there was this class
as a mechanism in these communities he
knew that and he tapped into it and how
great would it be because let me tell
you something
in the county that I grew up in
the poorest of the poor people the
people who would support Trump [ __ ]
hate cops they [ __ ] hate cops they if
a cop came on their property by God they
just might shoot that [ __ ] a lot
of times the law enforcement won't even
go on property without several agents
with them or officers with them because
they know they could get in a fire fight
because these people hate law
enforcement they're the same people that
vote for Trump they're saying people
vote for these Republicans saying back
the blue it doesn't make any sense it's
not supposed to make sense it is not
supposed to it's not but they don't care
because it's just what Texas Paul said
whatever they feel in the moment about
that in particular thing whether it be I
want a gun or I want to sell a gun
whatever I need to believe to do that
thing that's what I'm gonna believe and
I'll vote for anyone who's willing to
make sure that I can say that [ __ ]
because that's really what's going on
here they're trying to put people in
power to let them do whatever the [ __ ]
they want to do and by them I mean white
people why it's white supremacy through
and through this fentanyl [ __ ] when
you're [ __ ] because
I'm sure if you look up the statistics
of who's using fentanyl it ain't [ __ ]
Mexican people in America
it's not
that's not who's the majority that's
using [ __ ] fentanyl in this country
you know they got to get up and go to
work next day man God damn right but
here's the thing here's the thing
they're they they can't come to grips
with with their poor white State having
problems with fentanyl because they had
to suck on the teat a big Pharma
and they had to make sure that people
didn't get actual [ __ ] Health Care in
a delivery system and access to it that
now they're in a situation where they
have to keep lying and lying and lying
and lying and blaming it on brown people
blame it on this blame it on that
besides blame it on the actual problem
which is [ __ ] Republicans and [ __ ]
Republican policy because they don't
give a [ __ ]
about these people so much so that
they'll just tell them what they want to
believe not actually give them the facts
not tell them what they need to do to
fix the problem they'll just keep lying
to them and lying to them and lying to
them just like Marsha Blackburn did with
fentanyl just like this morning she did
with college with college student debt
relief she's they're [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] and they'll continue to do it if
you let them and you the voter are the
one who can stop this nonsense you have
the power to stop this nonsense
this is exactly you're exactly right
Tony you're exactly right and back me up
on this game because I'm sure you saw a
lot of this too people are like how can
Hispanic Americans vote for Trump and my
answer is always Cesar may act remember
says I may act he's the guy that mailed
the pipe bombs oh yeah yeah that he was
living in a van outside his job at at an
auto parts store
and he was an avid Trump supporter
because Trump told Cesar mayak that he
was better than me
he's better than you he's better than
Gabe because they just switched the
[ __ ] labels around and made it
Republican and Democrat Maga and
liberals
and scissor mayak would do anything to
preserve that feeling that he got in his
miserable [ __ ] life
where he was living in his [ __ ] van
and you know [ __ ] washing in the sink
in the back of an auto part parts store
that he was better than me
that his contribution his hard work
that's the part we don't play Tony when
we when we pull Marjorie Taylor green up
and we've played a stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
she says
the part that we don't play
is what comes after that
where she tells her audience but you
you're America you're what keeps us
going you have to carry them they live
off your back they get [ __ ] for free
they don't want to work they're lazy you
work hard you're the American
and poor Hispanics hard-working
[ __ ] that have been here are
buying into it they are buying into it
I'm telling you it's a problem here in
Texas Hispanic males voting Republican
is a problem here in Texas and it is the
same [ __ ] song man
different labels that's all it is
no no I'm finished
you know what I was I was done then oh
the only thing I'll say to that is it is
as someone from the Hispanic Community
it does hurt to see people from
in some regard from the people that I
that I'm a part of to see them vote
Republican right because you might be
like well well it could be Catholicism
and religion it could be just indoctrine
indoctrination it could also be the fact
that a lot of these people feel like
they need to belong right you're already
an outsider you come into a country that
already hates you
um The self-hatred Falls in you you feel
like you need to assimilate into our
culture and one of the things is you
gotta be uh anti you know non-american
right you need anti-immigrant even
though you yourself or your family might
have come from that right
and so
I know people who are like that and it
does for me it kills me inside to know
that they're voting against their own
best interests to know that they're
supporting a group of people who doesn't
who don't actually care about them right
we saw it with with Venezuela
Venezuelans seeking Asylum with um with
uh with DeSantis right we see the way
that Greg Abbott treats immigrants we
treat these people who are seeking a
better life as just complete [ __ ] right
as political pawns as soon as as soon as
you serve the purpose or if you betray
the party or whatever you're done you're
out they don't give a [ __ ] who you are
as long as you move them forward to that
checkmate and that is what these people
are to them that's that's all they are
they're they're nothing more than an
object on a chess board that they need
to move around and you know if they need
to sacrifice you so be it and so when I
see people within my own community
vote that way support those things say
those things I I very much throws me
off my game because it's not something
that I think would be inherently the way
that you would want to go especially
when Trump says you know in his his uh
announcement speech in 2015 he goes oh
all those Mexicans that come across the
border they're rapists and drug dealers
and criminals and all these things like
straight out of the gate just dog
whistle blowing it loud and clear and
there are still people
whether it's you know
um a a grooming or indoctrination or
they really do fear look I'm already an
outsider if I don't play by the rules of
what you're saying then I am now going
to be the target
and they're not considered they're not
you know they're not considered people
by Republican standards you know they're
they're a they're a piece of a person
not a full human being that that they
treat their fellow white person
um and yeah and like Tony said there's a
classism aspect as well like if you're
part of a class and you're better than a
lo you know it's [ __ ] up the way that
we live in this country and it's also
[ __ ] up the way that we treat other
people
um and it's even more [ __ ] up that
there are people within the Hispanic
Community or the black community or the
Asian community that will die by the way
of the Republican party because they're
they are in my way I I look at their
betraying their own people they are they
are uh you know and uh
an enemy of of their own group because
they're not doing what actually would
benefit them they're doing the thing
that they'll you know in in this country
we learn that it's
you do what you need to do for yourself
and don't consider anyone else it's
isolationist and it's there's no group
mentality in there
so
I don't know that's what I want yeah and
you hit that right on the head there's
no group mentality and the Republicans
attack that they pick at those cracks
they pick at those cracks incessantly
they sell in the Hispanic community's
anti-black rhetoric anti-asian rhetoric
they and they they tell but like you
remember the the Biden bus that got it
oh that crazy bastard yeah almost run
off that road yeah there's a guy by the
name of Ellie I went to school with that
sumbitch
did you really yeah yeah I did I know
him his cousin is a friend of mine
I I'm not even kidding his cousin's a
[ __ ] Trumper to you man I tell you
what I
[Music]
Eloy if you're listening God damn it
Eloy but anyways uh Ellie
was [ __ ] nuts man and he and he
listened to that [ __ ] he listened to
these [ __ ] Texas Republicans man
talking [ __ ] about how blacks were
getting all the welfare and you know
Asians were treated so well out in
California and this that and the other
he [ __ ] turned into
a racist
he turned into a [ __ ] racist you know
and it was him they kept telling him the
same goddamn lie you worked so hard you
work so hard and everybody else has it
so easy and they're taken from you and
they sing in this [ __ ] song to these
people and they do they divide
you know groups that should be tighter
than tight man
I mean I and they just divide them with
the same [ __ ] rhetoric well but
they've done it even I mean if you look
at the Second Amendment even they act
like this is some kind of individual
right like it's your your individual
god-given right like it's something that
you only you have the right to to arm
yourself which that's not at all what
the Second Amendment says and this this
sickness of individualism in this
country because there is individualism
we should have the liberty of
individualism and I mean have the
liberty of it but not to be required and
mandated to have individualism because
that's what causes this classism because
folks what I just described in white
communities doesn't just happen in white
communities and it's the reason why is
because exactly what Texas Paul said
they like to drive those wedges into
cracks they continue it and this idea
that Hispanics don't have this well the
the dichotomy of hey well at least I'm
not as low as this person or in this
community they say well at least I'm not
as low as this person over there in that
Community or at least it it exists in
our country it exists in our DNA it
exists in us institutionally that's the
whole purpose and that's what they're
taking advantage of and they're taking
advantage of the lie because it's all
[ __ ] lies I mean it's all [ __ ]
lies it's just nonsense it's just
[ __ ] I mean us three we're all three
[ __ ] human and any other humans we
get on here they would be human I mean
maybe other than Ted Cruz Ted Cruz is
questionable just saying it really is
have you seen Ted Cruz he he might be a
lizard I'm just saying no he might be a
little he's a bit of a blob right but
here's the thing
is that as long as long as we let them
get away with these lies
little big or whatever because that's
how it starts and that's how they're
doing this is little by little by little
just these little lies here little lies
there little lies here little lies there
and they take advantage of what I called
earlier classism inside these
communities and they create it into this
problem where it's this community now
against this community now
um where it wasn't it's not that's not
near the truth and that's how we get to
the situation where they absolutely will
not do anything about the fentanyl
problem the actual fentanyl problem
meaning the health care problem of
fentanyl because that's the fentanyl
problem we have it's a health care issue
it's a health care
problem and only Health Care policy will
fix it that's it building a wall having
some kind of [ __ ] ban on this or ban
on that or something kind of you can't
ship it here or can't ship it there you
can regulate the [ __ ] out of it all you
want in the manufacturing process of
this stuff but if you don't fix the
[ __ ] Health Care problem people are
going to seek out the opioid they're
going to because the problem is the
health care problem we have derived from
opioids I hate to tell you that I hate
to say it like that but that's that's
the issue that we have that's the issue
and we're dealing with it with this in
the stupidest way possible too you know
in Portugal they decriminalized all
drugs
they do decriminalized all this I didn't
say they made them legal and said hey
you can smoke heroin on the street and
[ __ ] like no they just decriminalized
if you have a drug problem meaning they
don't lock you up in a jail
if you are an addict
they will put you in treatment you will
keep your job
you will not go to jail and be a drain
on the Portuguese Portuguese people you
will keep your [ __ ] job
you'll go to work you'll take care of
your family and they will give you
treatment for your addiction if you're
an addict and you know what else they
found out
this [ __ ] isn't as addicting as we they
portrayed it to be that [ __ ] coming out
of the Reagan that
that whole [ __ ] Reefer Madness
[ __ ] was [ __ ]
only 10 of people that use [ __ ] and I'm
not [ __ ] preaching using drugs people
don't do it don't do it because you
could be one of the one in [ __ ] ten
but only ten percent of the people they
did a study a real study
only 10 percent of the people that
utilize heroin became addicted
most didn't even want to use it again
because they didn't like the entire I
don't get drunk a lot guys because I
don't like the feeling of intoxication
that doesn't do it for me I don't like
being intoxicated
you know I don't I don't like that
feeling of being out of control is that
what you is that what you prefer Texas
ball I mean you can be honest with us
you know I may I I may go to uh you know
Colorado every once in a while
you're going hunting it's a hunting trip
right exactly we love cutting in
Colorado yeah just the fact that it's
not hunting season I'll ignore that
right right well you're hunting
yeah yeah hunting Bear yeah there you go
I like that I'm gonna use that for now
on unbear
but you know
Portugal has been wildly successful with
this
but our law enforcement industry and
it's an industry in this country doesn't
want that they scream every time they
talk about legalizing marijuana because
it is the number one thing that they use
to Parlay into other crimes
you know he didn't get out of his car
fast enough so I had to yank him out of
his car and when I yanked him out of his
car he grabbed a hold of my shirt and
that is you know that's another charge
right there you know you and now the
private prison industry has has somebody
that they can hold for six months and
make money off of and you know his
family's [ __ ] over and and and now
he's got an arrest on his record that
officer gets a notch on their belt and
then they can get another notch and
another notch and another notch and how
easy it to get notch on belts for Gummy
Bears
um yeah I think that well
the one thing I want to add to that is
like you know textball brings up a point
about just treating and you know again
we've talked about this before is like
treating humans like humans right having
empathy which is something that the
Republican Party lacks uh to its [ __ ]
core whether it's knowing how to design
apps or just treating people like people
right there was a lack of empathy that
the Republican Party has in in
addressing or approaching anything
they're trying to solve or any problem
or just anything in life right and this
is an example where you would say oh
yeah cool this person they got addicted
and we're gonna help treat them
to get them better right to get them
back on their feet to get them back in
their home to get them back at work
right to actually uh contribute to our
economy in our community instead of
saying well you're a drug addict and
you're now been stigmatized and you're
now homeless and now you don't have a
family and now you lost your job and now
you have this like all of these things
and then the Republican party goes well
you're just a lazy drug addict and
that's all you are and that's what the
and that's what those people see and
it's like no wonder people
you know do more drugs or commit suicide
or whatever it is right you've got a
group of people
who just
berates them down and down and down and
says that you're not worthy you're not
good instead of saying hey look we might
have [ __ ] you over with this problem
by introducing these drugs and not
regulating the market and not actually
having a system in place to help you
they say ah you can go [ __ ] yourselves
which is like again what Republicans do
for any problem or any issue instead of
actually saying oh you're a fellow human
I would want the same courtesy on myself
if I was going through the similar
problem as you are but instead they go
you're lazy you're a drug addict you're
this you're this you're this you're this
so just give you labels and labels and
labels but then that person is like well
I guess then all I am is what you say I
am and and then you obviously see that
the worst results possible because you
just abandoned your fellow
you know Community member Christian you
know whatever you want to call it but
that is what Republicans will do and
they'll just say
see ya
and that's why the freest country on
Earth has has more people locked up in
prison than anyone else in the world we
lead the world in the number of people
that we've taken their freedom from and
because of exactly what you're talking
about Gabe because you hit it right on
the damn head when we were faced with a
problem when when communities I'm
talking about black communities I don't
I don't know if you guys are old enough
to remember Cabrini Green up in Chicago
yeah yeah you're from Chicago yeah they
took a look at that problem and there
were two ways they could have went they
could have went the way that that
historically we know worked which was
when they ended prohibition
the [ __ ] gangsters stopped being
violent
they could have ended the violence that
way or you can Ultra
police this and make it Ultra illegal
and come up with harsher you know three
strikes in your out rules and and and
[ __ ] like that and you can dump a [ __ ]
ton of money into ruining people's lives
for using drugs and guess which way we
went
and it was the African-American
communities it was you know it was the
black communities it was the Hispanic
communities that were telling people you
have to do something about this we got a
violence problem we've got to drive by
far I don't know if y'all know about the
80s and the 90s
you know [ __ ] people shooting like
this I mean if you think hillbillies are
bad with guns you ought to see drug
dealers with guns Jesus Christ man you
know I mean and the worst the worst part
about that you bring caprini green and
it really goes to show you which is like
certain policies in place in in the
mentality we have towards how to solve
these problems is uh it was in two when
I was I graduated high school and they
were beginning the demolition of caprini
green and so I can tell you that it's
you know there's a 30-year cycle where
you have these empty nesters they move
into the city they move out and their
solution was hey instead of actually uh
providing a solution or an alternative
to what Cabrini Green should be uh we're
now going to ship you out to the suburbs
and we're going to demolish this and
we're going to build a Target or the
shopping center and a bunch of condos
instead over this area that we gave you
uh and I mean I I would I I watched it
growing up as a kid and then I witnessed
the demolition of this and coming back
to Chicago I see people displaced from
their homes not having a place to go
then you have this this hyper uh you
know this gentrification and also
polarization of wealth between two
groups that once was there as as Section
8 housing or low income housing and then
you have this group of you know young 20
30 year roles who are now living in
these high rises as as a as as a
replacement and so it's whether it's the
policing but then once the problem gets
too bad and you're like well this is
great real estate they say all right you
guys got to go and they don't offer them
an actual solution
yeah yeah I mean exactly exactly what I
was saying the the the solutions that
they come up with and and this was
during the Clinton Administration when
this happened it was you had the Clinton
Administration appeasing the black
community
with these radical law enforcement
policies that created help create this
massive prison industry we have today
because it was the wrong damn thing to
do because
why and why am I going to end up playing
blaming Republicans for this because
every goddamn Republican who's running
on Law and Order every goddamn
Republican was running on get tough
selling this [ __ ] so if Democrats
ran on well you know what let's just do
make this not illegal and we'll give
them treatment and this that and the
other you seem like a pansy and you lose
your [ __ ] election because
[ __ ] bright up in Nebraska scared of
them people you know he's gonna vote for
that [ __ ]
and I'm telling you cookouts cookouts is
how we fix this [ __ ] I I know it sounds
like a goddamn joke but I'm telling you
the truth we have become an isolated
people
we sit in our houses I sit out here in
my freaking woods man I force myself to
go interact with people so that I can
keep in touch and keep that you
we have gated communities where people
literally Drive in their gated community
drive into their garage shut their
garage door they do not talk to their
neighbors they don't know their
neighbors they don't know what's going
on they barely see the kids you know
Friday Night Football used to be a
social event man you go to one now
nobody talks
no one talks to each other they sit they
face forward when something good happens
they go yay when something bad happens
they go boom and that's it
they don't speak to each other anymore
and [ __ ] cookouts will fix that man
I'm telling you you spend time I went to
an event for uh you know I always help
out Democratic groups I do I all the
time I went to an event and one of the
groups there was the first
transgender transgender gender
motorcycle gang
they call themselves The Factory Rejects
I'm not kidding it's a transgender
motorcycle game
and you cannot hang out with those
people because after about five minutes
you forget their transgender people and
they're just people right and they had
the coolest freaking dog there man this
Doberman was gorgeous and I was like I
wanted a pet can I pet that dog
I want to do so bad but that dog would
not warm up to me at all but and I don't
know why dogs normally love me but you
don't you hang out with people and all
of a sudden they're not the other
anymore
and that's how we fix it man that's how
we fix it we have got to get people not
just packed into a stadium where they're
not freaking talking to each other Texas
Paul I'm gonna be onto something here
hang on a second I think you're onto
something we've got to have cookies I'm
running out of time but I think what we
should do is have Liberty cookouts I
think he's on to something here audience
I mean just have Liberty cookouts
everywhere make this a [ __ ] thing
make this a culture where we invite
everybody anybody and anybody wants to
come to cookout by God come to the
cookout because there's nothing there's
nothing better than food to get people
together to get them talking and to get
them laughing well actually
I was thinking about Gabe what do you
think about the adopt a white boy
program
I mean honestly you could you could you
could bring a lot of change you br you
bring a white boy into a home especially
that of a culture you know oh my God the
seasons they will have the the the types
of food Tapas like all around I mean
just the the
you know I think there is something
where it's like oh I'm gonna have a
study abroad student come over I'm going
to adopt a white boy and just help them
understand what the [ __ ] is going on in
this country and the real people that
are here and understand the culture I
totally agree I think that's a real
thing that we should do okay well let's
I am not kidding Gabe I am not kidding
because white people are scared they're
gonna invite a black guy over and it's
going to be the quietest [ __ ] dinner
you ever had and there's going to be
mayonnaise as a seasoning you have an
adopt a white boy program you have an
adopt a white boy program and you take a
white boy out of the burbs and you bring
them into the hood and you show them
some real barbecue and you show him some
music and people out there dancing
having a good time drinking a few beers
next thing you know
everybody's living in a gentrified
neighborhood oh white boy I'm just
kidding I'm just
kidding I gotta I've gotta end it Texas
Paul this is supposed to be a 30 minute
thing and every week it gets longer and
longer and I'm super excited about it
I'm happy about this the audience loves
it we love having you here every single
Tuesday uh tell them tell them where
they can go to find your YouTube channel
next week you cannot I have to make an
announcement I'm doing some traveling I
always keep it real and I do what I do I
I really support things and you're gonna
love what I do next week but the next
week I will be out there will be no
shows but you can find me on Sunday
afternoon competing with the Sunday
shows with Sunday coffee with Texas Paul
you can find me on uh uh on Wednesday
evenings it used to be Wednesday
evenings we're moving to Tuesdays and
Thursdays immediately following the uh
the Midas touch podcast or TN Tennessee
Brando and I do TNT we're going to do it
on Tuesdays and Thursday evenings but
not next week next week I've got some
things going on and you're going to love
the footage when I get back and I want
to thank Jen for mailing me the
California republic shirt she was you
know where there was a conversation
where people were trash talk in Texas
and I had to explain to them that that
Texas is not all the stereotypes you
hear that they're more people like me
than there are people like Greg Abbott
and [ __ ] walleye Paxton and all those
people and the Houston is the most
diversity in the country
and by the end of the conversation he
got in touch with Miss Texas Mrs Texas
Paul got our P.O box and mailed me a
California Republic shirt and I'm
wearing the [ __ ] out of this thing I
love it I love this shirt I love it so
everyone go follow Texas Paul on on
YouTube just go to his link tree I think
it's link tree slash Texas Paul isn't it
just go to link link tr.e Texas Paul
that's right so go to Texas Paul
linktree find all the links there for
social media Texas Paul until next
Tuesday I'll stay in the chat with you
my friend
I'm telling you let's do it man we'll
start we'll start a GoFundMe and adopt a
white boy program
you know we'll get families
we'll get black families Hispanic
families Asian families to adopt
middle-aged white boys that are you know
and bring them out for the cookouts and
the next thing you know
I mean the only way to break to break
generational racism right is to is to
smash It smash it with some barbecue
right that's it we'll smash it with some
culture smash it with some food smash it
with something that's it that's it
thanks thanks for joining us everyone
stick around we'll be right back for a
little bit of [ __ ] let's round up just a
little bit right after this break we'll
we'll stick around we'll be right back
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
longer and longer every week
Amanda says here in the chat three hours
three hours three hours
[Music]
Roundup but we have a loud lightning
round today
Mr Sanchez and we're going to do a
lightning round here's here's Amanda's
comment three hours three hours three
hours
I don't know I I think we could manage
to do five or six yeah I mean we've done
we've done five hours consistently
through all of the uh hearings no
problem no problem no problem but we got
a lot of stuff to get to because we had
some debates last night but the first
thing I want to show here on the [ __ ]
list Roundup is Marcia
what a [ __ ] idiot this is actually
disinfuriated the [ __ ] out of me this
morning absolutely got me [ __ ] pissed
that she can tell this [ __ ] line did
you see this clip I haven't seen this
clip but I know I've been waiting I've
been waiting to watch it okay on the
show so let's do this let's do the [ __ ]
list Roundup because we got we got this
clip and we got several of the debate
Clips so don't stick around because
we're gonna go through these debate
Clips it's gonna be lightning round but
we're gonna go through them stick around
[ __ ] let's round up right now
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
podcast the lightning round shitless
Roundup where we ran up all the Tweety
tweets and the training Trends this is
the first time this is the title of the
show this is the the damn clip I was
talking about in the first 30 minutes
that absolutely pissed me the [ __ ] off
this is the reason why well there's a
lot of reasons but today this is the
reason why Marsha Blackburn should be
asked to resign I'm not [ __ ] you
this clip right here listen to this Gabe
um that student loan debt forgiveness
and that is a gift to the rich this is
something that has infuriated
tennesseans and as I've been okay I'm
gonna stab right there she's going to
talk about the [ __ ] football game and
all kinds of [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
about that she literally Lee says
says that the student debt program
Gabe Sanchez
is a gift to the rich I can't even begin
to tell you how pissed off I was that a
United States sitting Senator would go
on a national TV program sit in front of
a microphone and a [ __ ] camera and
say such a dumb [ __ ] thing now she is
either
she is either not fit to be a United
States Senator because she can't handle
the brain power to figure out facts from
fiction or she's [ __ ] lying to people
and it's an outright line I'm going to
show you why but give me your give me
your thoughts on this now that you've
seen this clip it makes no sense how is
this a gift to the rich I I do rich
people take [ __ ] student loans but
also the fact that this is for people
who make under seventy five thousand
dollars exactly so I don't know unless I
mean unless she's saying that someone
who makes 75 000 or less is rich in
Tennessee I don't know if that's what's
going on here but this is the woman who
you know doesn't
God you know had to ask the question
what is a woman right and had to you
know this woman is whenever I see her I
always feel like she's like five glasses
deep into a box of wine you know uh and
she's using a glass I figured she'd just
like well no that's uh that's Judge Jean
that's uh that's uh yeah you know you
can see how I get those yeah but for
someone like this who says this this
doesn't make any sense I don't know what
I don't I don't know exactly what she's
exactly how this argument is working for
her right now to to again like it's
pretty straightforward to say like who
qualifies for this loan forgiveness
program
but specifically this isn't something
that would benefit the rich what
benefits the rich would be tax cuts like
Trump did during his presidency that
benefits the rich you know the fact that
we added more to our deficit uh than
actually trying to combat it which I
think uh this year we're on we're on
track to reducing the deficit by 1.5
trillion dollars Oh you mean Democrats
reduced deficit stats it's crazy this is
the website here Gabe this is the
federal student aid website it's
studentaid.gov
studentaid.gov this is literally the
website where you go to apply for this
thing now if you read here it says
welcome to studentaid.gov you are
looking for a student don't debt relief
normally you know a little bit about
building websites right do you know why
it well you know why but I'm asking this
rhetorically but I want your opinion
here
do you know why it took it was not that
long that it took the federal government
to build a website to figure out who was
going to apply
for student loan relief do you know why
they had that do you know why it was so
easy other than like the healthcare
website which is a whole other animal
right all right do you need a reason why
it's really simple and if Marcia
Blackburn was a United States sitting
Senator maybe she would know this that
the aid that they are relieving is
federal aid that the federal government
gave those people it they they already
know who the P they are the lender you
dumb [ __ ] they're the they're
the lender okay so yeah it's pretty I
mean like to break it down for anyone
who who might not know how this is going
to work I haven't looked at this this
actual uh
but how I would imagine is
we have a government uh agency you know
there's uh they have a database stuff
they have a database of names Social
Security numbers like own amounts right
how many payments right that's right it
probably figures a lot of it like
automatically right and I'm gonna assume
that obviously the unique identifier
which is what we use when it comes to
databases is going to be your social
security number wait wait you mean you
mean there's a goddamn number do you
mean there's a number that you use to
identify yourself to the federal
government and the governments in
general are you telling me that if the
federal government knows that you want
this student debt relief all they would
need is that number to tie it to your
loan debt to see if you qualify to
actually give you that relief come on
Gabe you're being a little out of hand
here this I'm just saying they might
they might ask for more I mean they'll
probably ask for more information but
let me show you because it says here
time to complete five minutes oh easy
you do not have to log in and there are
no no documents required because they
already have them it's they're the
[ __ ] lender okay so we're gonna start
this application now I'm gonna I'm gonna
guess this takes uh three minutes tops
right
I don't have student debt I paid it all
off years ago and I'm not pissed off
that I'm not getting my student debt
relief because I already got it relieved
I already paid it off now it gives you
some instructions here but here's the
deal you put your first name middle
initial that's optional you don't have
to do it last name oh former last name
that's optional you know in case you had
changed your name
um hey look here social security number
look there's social security number and
then they want you to confirm it and
then they want you to put your date of
birth everyone's got one of those do we
net your phone number your email you
gotta confirm that email and then and
then you go down and you say yeah
everything's cool you fill out your name
again as this digital signature you
click the little button box and you hit
submit yep that's a [ __ ] let me
tell you something if you have Google
Chrome and you have your forms already
uh auto fill this would take you less
than 30 seconds to fill out here's why
Marsha Blackburn is such a pile of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
let me show you
right here okay she is saying that rich
people now you have to sign you have to
[ __ ] sign under penalty of federal
law and perjury
to the to this right here
I made less than the requirement income
to file federal taxes I filed as a
single tax Filer and made less than a
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
less than not more than less than did
they change it I thought it was 75 000.
well it it depends now it goes on to say
I was married filed my taxes separately
and made less than a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars I was married
filed my taxes jointly and made less
than does Marsha Blackburn not know it
less than maybe this is the problem
maybe this is the [ __ ] problem is
this little phrase less than I think
she's having difficult difficulties
figuring out what the word less than
means when it comes to a number I've got
a I've got an example ready okay
uh fascism oh okay is less than okay uh
democracy oh that is a good example now
Marshall Blackburn will not get that
example either this is really [ __ ]
dumb this is really [ __ ] stupid and
the re Gabe I said it in the first 30
minutes the reason why Marshall
Blackburn and Jim Jordan and all these
[ __ ] these fascists keep saying
this is because they're hoping their
constituents do not apply for this
[ __ ] student debt relief right they
want to make sure that their
constituents do not get this they do not
benefit from it and the reason why is
because it may just may it may just may
get them to go and maybe that whole
student net relief thing wasn't so bad I
mean Biden or you know let's go Brandon
Mike the student debt thing wasn't so
bad I think the real problem that
Republicans have right now especially
like Marsha Blackburn
uh brain burn
brain Marshall Blackburn um I feel like
the the issue that Republicans have
right now
is that student debt loan forgiveness
is the Gateway policy
to uh
to supporting Democrats I think I think
you think it's like the gateway drug
yeah of socialism right I think what's
going to happen is is there fear is that
these people sign up and go oh [ __ ] I
just reduced my loan by up to twenty
thousand dollars or whatever it might be
right whatever you qualify for and they
go oh my God I can now use that money
for food my child my apartment or my
home uh my car payments my insurance
payments My Health Care payments like
all of these things they'd be like oh
[ __ ] I've now saved money that I can
spend because again this is not money
that's being given to you like these
Republicans want to claim it is it's not
like you're eating a stipend you're
getting money cut off from your normal
monthly uh bills that's what you're
doing so then you say oh great I spend
less here so I can spend more here all
right
they don't want they don't want this to
be successful because they don't want it
because it it literally is going to free
up discretionary income that is going to
to drive the economy even further the
reason why and again I can't even
believe we have to [ __ ] go over this
again and again and again inflation
inflation folks it feels bad because
your wages aren't going up yeah that's
why it feels bad inflation is good for
our economy it is bad for you because
our system isn't creating a mechanism
for your wages to inflate milk and gas
are not that expensive you don't have
the [ __ ] money to buy the milk and
gas that's the problem and it's not that
you're you don't have the labor or the
ability to trade something for that
money it's just they're not the
inflation of the labor is not happening
it's the labor that is not inflating
that is the problem that we're having
and when Joe Biden and the
administration recognizes that because
they know that Gabe they know that
inflation is happening but labor
inflation is not happening the cost of
Labor is not Rising like the cost of
goods which means the people who sell
labor workers aren't getting that
[ __ ] money that they that they should
have in the economy so what the
administration is trying to do is find
ways to give people discretionary
spending and the ability to to to try to
beat back on inflation than the price of
goods by giving people more income one
easy way for the federal government to
do that is to look at federal student
debt and go holy [ __ ] this thing's
really dragging these people down most
of them most of them are even causing a
larger Problem by by by uh
curtailing this debt and interest piling
on top of it when we could just relieve
them of it now and they did that during
the pandemic that's the other [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing that I'm sick and tired
of hearing under the Trump
Administration he created an a national
crisis a national economic crisis by
putting tariffs all around the world on
our foreign Goods
and that [ __ ] destroyed
destroyed markets that farmers built for
decades and decades and decades to
export our Goods all around the world
that was their markets that they sold
their Farm Goods in rather it was Lumber
rather it was a livestock whether it was
a food good or produce whatever it was
yeah or even Electronics like I worked
in the in the electronic component
industry for a while during this tariff
when when Trump decided he was going to
be the great businessman that he was by
imposing tariffs and then the you know
and if you impose a tariff which is a
tax let's call what it is on to
something that country that it is going
to say okay fine well to offset the cost
of this tariff or not we're gonna throw
a tariff back on you right we're not
going to trade with you anymore yeah so
they'll go find it cheaper someplace
else so they didn't buy from our farmers
and it [ __ ] our farmers and they were
pissed and the one thing that Trump did
right
which he created the entire crisis he
manufactured the entire crisis but the
one thing that he did write is he he
knew that the federal government should
write a check because the federal
government his federal government [ __ ]
the farmers just like during the
pandemic the federal government knew
that that people are [ __ ] it's not
their fault it's not via it's not within
their control they wrote a check they
wrote several checks during the pandemic
is our [ __ ] country in in Dire
Straits is the economy crashing because
of it no the economy is inflating
because of it all that horseshit that
they feed you about government
government money government spending and
you can't give money to the people that
is all [ __ ] horseshit all of it the
whole [ __ ] line is a lie to convince
you that you shouldn't get a government
handout it's not a government handout
it's your [ __ ] money we are the
government we are the government Jesus
Christ Elon Musk the richest person in
the world he's so brilliant he's so
smart he's so rich he's begging begging
for [ __ ] for [ __ ] government money
for starlink after he said he wouldn't
that [ __ ] which also the
ukrainians are paying for I mean there's
literal receipts on Twitter if anyone
wants to search for this he's
complaining about not being he's like oh
well I guess I'm gonna lose money every
day and ukrainians are tweeting out bank
statements to be like oh this is what my
money is going to and it's literally
right startling this is the amount
that's going out but this is the game
this is the game to convince you to
convince you that government money bad
government money bad listen the
government is the lender for these
[ __ ] loans it is our money that we
are charging higher interest rates on to
American people to get ahead in the
economy by getting a college education
we the people own the debt and we can
make it easier on the economy by getting
rid of this debt and that's why Joe
Biden did it and that's why these people
do not want these people to get these
loans are the this debt relief they do
not want them they want they want their
constituents to hurt they want Americans
to hurt because they want to say see how
bad you're hurting under Joe Biden see
how bad the economy is under job look at
inflation look at inflation don't ignore
your wages look at inflation look at the
price of milk ignore how much money you
had to pay for milk look at the price of
milk that's what they're doing that's
what they're doing and we need to fight
back and I think JD Vance
got his ass kicked last night with Tim
Ryan fighting back with the seems to be
a trend with the truth and facts in real
time just like we do here on the Tony
Michaels podcast run out of time this is
one of my favorite Clips I actually
clipped this together so I apologize for
the um
I don't think it's amateur right I mean
it's not that bad I mean it looks looks
good to me so far we'll see how it plays
but it looks good to me so far well you
didn't watch this yeah okay well here's
here's how I clipped the guy because I
did this you know for like social media
for like Instagram and I cut the front
end of this clip off but this is a clip
of Tim Ryan saying hey you said Alex
Jones is a reliable source of
information and here here's the here's
the one minute ditty with the evidence
at the end from from Sandy Hook
absolutely devastated you lose a fourth
grader to a to a Madman
and this guy says it was a hoax
our guy JD says this is one of the most
credible news sources in the whole
country and he just got convicted and he
just got sued to the tune of billions of
dollars that he owes the family for
putting them through this grief and I
just want people to know it's like
we are running for the United States
Senate
this is the highest office you could get
in this country except for president and
he's running around backing these
extremists the most extreme people in
the country a guy who've done that
denied Sandy Hawk he's like you know
he's credible thank you I mean you don't
have to I mean it's just it's maddening
this is a complete fabrication
I never said that to him no one run the
tape and find out exactly what it'll be
like 30 minutes
okay so not only did JD man say [ __ ]
like this in front of a camera he also
tweeted [ __ ] like this yeah so I just
took the tweet that he tweeted and I put
it up there on the screen and of course
I added the little sound effect because
JD Vance is a [ __ ] joke
um but I I want to point out that my
editing here and I'm just now noticing
this that it looks like Tim Ryan is on a
word cloud here and he's hanging over
yeah yeah build back look at this it
really looks like he's
he is um word clouding over JD Vance
because I had to cut it where it was on
time
just floating floating uh you know just
floating a curtain background it doesn't
give much of a break here maybe I should
have I don't know again we all know here
who does the best video editing
um yeah right yeah
I just need a word cloud right there
oh my God the debate last night what was
some of the highlights that you enjoyed
the most uh I mean I think I I think uh
one of my favorite again is just this
tactic of calling them out and being
like you you you kissed his ass you
kissed Trump's ass you called him
America's Hitler you kisses that he's
like no I did it no I it's like dude one
there's literally received a receipt two
but it you did say it I called you on it
last time and even though I said it
again you didn't even have any way to to
like you know you couldn't come up with
an excuse you couldn't come up with any
reason why you said it you knew I was
probably going to say this again and you
still said [ __ ] you said oh no that's
not true that's not true no no reason
why no excuse you literally said the
same thing and then you came back and
was like oh no no no no that's not true
and it's it's
crazy because
you don't have to come up with crazy
tactics to call these fascists out for
their hypocrisy or the projection or
whatever it might be you just got to say
the same [ __ ] over and over again you
got to repeat it you got to repeat it
you got to repeat it you got to repeat
it and this is one of those times where
it's like
he knew what was coming and he did not
prepare for it well it it's it's not
surprising that they don't prepare for
it I want to leave with this video here
this is the same exact thing the same
exact thing that you're talking about
and the good liars are and Masters at
this um this Trump supporter he has a
buck fighting cheered on I'm sure he's a
Christian
um
I don't know why they all want to Buck
fighting I don't know why they I don't
know it's weird it's really weird that
they want to have sex with him yeah
um I mean I like Joe but I like the Loan
program even I think that's one of the
best things he's done you know the
inflation I'm not trying to [ __ ] him
though right I don't want to [ __ ] him
that's kind of weird okay right right
they're always talking about how Joe
Biden's creepy but you people really
seem to want to [ __ ] him really bad okay
so this guy here with this
this I I don't know how to describe his
look here with the hat and the
sunglasses it's it's um typical Maga but
let's let's listen to the interview here
before we go I saw Trump I mean come on
the guy's a genius yeah you know media
goes around telling him telling us that
he's stupid right he's an idiot right
the guy's a genius
I you know I I could hardly he's like is
this even real like this is one of those
things where you're like are you serious
right now it feels like it really does
feel like sometimes the good liars and
maybe we should have him on the show to
ask him like are you paying people to
dress up like this do you find these
people on Craigslist that you know just
like the people that show up at the
rallies but this is one of those things
where you hear the guy go yeah well he's
a genius I mean the media is saying that
he's an idiot and he's dumb but he's a
genius
why why is he a genius for what reason I
don't know if he explains oh oh it gets
good it gets good we're only halfway
into this but this is the same JD Vance
thing right this guy believes that he's
a genius and he's never been challenged
on it before maybe yeah uh but JD Vance
has so you think JD Vance would have
some kind of like you know
some sort of [ __ ] rebuttal
watch what happens when he asks why he's
a genius and then follows it up with
another question
I mean look what he did with his uh you
know built his uh construction companies
and stuff you know well he did go
bankrupt a couple times
he did
I mean also he doesn't did he own
construction companies well I mean I'm
saying they they he's a developer right
right so like he didn't actually own the
construction and he also he hired a
construction company and never [ __ ]
paid him is right that's one right I
mean Trump said it during the 2016
debates with Hillary Clinton there when
she called him out for not paying his
taxes he goes well that just makes me a
good businessman that just means that
you're [ __ ] over everyone else right
because you found some loophole in the
tax code that would allow you to not pay
your actual fair share of the taxes but
that makes a good Mark man I'm so smart
with my tax policy and and Tish James
says hold my beer yeah he's like I got
you I'm coming for you okay okay this
James is gonna speaking of which yeah
they uh I think I read yesterday that uh
that Trump and Don Jr were finally
served yes they were they had been
avoiding her for like three weeks
I think is it today or tomorrow that he
I think it's Wednesday so it is tomorrow
yeah the judge is forcing and says no
you you you can't get out of this this
is a thing that you have to you have to
and that's not a separate that's that's
the right that's a whole killer one
that's the right [ __ ] I we I
would we just need to uh shoot to Sean
Hannity in here yeah I know scroll is a
list of all the crimes and all the
[ __ ] criminal and civil cases that
this guy's a part of because he's a
scumbag
um but you know Buck feiden you know
Buck him yeah you know Buck him buck the
fight oh by the way one more thing
before we go yeah James James Biden was
trending this morning James yeah I saw
that I didn't even click into it but I
was like is there someone I don't know
about well uh Chuck Grassley tweeted
about Hunter
and James Biden I said
I tweeted
does James Biden own a laptop
is this is this laptop in the room with
this right now will the real James Biden
please stand up I because I don't know
who that is uh well apparently Joe Biden
has a brother named James I don't know
if that's who Chuck Grassley he's
talking about or not but apparently
um dark Brandon has a brother named
James and he might or might not own a
laptop I'm not really sure everybody
thanks for joining us maybe we'll sniff
out the uh the James Biden stuff
tomorrow I'm sure there'll be plenty of
news piled on top of past James Biden's
laptop everyone go to
store.thetonymichaels.com grab your the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty hoodies and zip
hoodies it's getting cold out there
don't forget to stay warm when Liberty's
game I think I'm gonna put a sweater on
the way website to keep people warm that
way when they go to the polls they can
sport their Liberty gear and stay warm
you can get a t-shirt too the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty go to
store.thetonymichaels.com thank you for
all your support the audience here the
greatest audience in the world here at
the Tony Michaels podcast same time same
place tomorrow noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
don't forget to subscribe if you're on
YouTube right now and also download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
Google and if you're on Facebook right
now go over and follow us at the Tony
Michaels that little clip you've seen of
JD Vance
and Tim Ryan I posted that on Facebook
so I'm going to be trying to post a
little more clips and memes over there
on Facebook so go follow at the Tony
Michaels follow us there you can also
watch the broadcast live there as well
every single weekday Monday through
Friday same time same place tomorrow
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon